hello everyone good evening welcome to
the Santa Fe Institute public lecture
series in our new venue which is
absolutely gorgeous for those who are
new to these events I just remind you of
why we do them and there are three
primary motivations for holding these
public lectures one and I've read them
out is to promote conversation and
debate around complexity science here in
Santa Fe and through our videos online
globally around the world so it's rather
evangelical the second objective is
really just to shine a spotlight on
ideas and frameworks and people who we
think are making a constructive
contribution to rational debate in the
world and finally really enriching the
lives of people everywhere so those are
our objectives and I should say again
you know this is a new partnership with
a lens it for us and we're just
delighted and I think we have 800 people
at this event this evening
I want you to acknowledge
Thornburg for their continued support of
the public lecture series I'd like to be
able to acknowledge many more people and
companies that's a hint in case you were
wondering and so if any of you feel
inclined to make a contribution to the
Santa Fe Institute and our outreach
activities I'd encourage you to do so I
believe there are envelopes very
capacious envelopes somewhere in the
lobby and you know we're just delighted
to be kicking off this series with
tonight's incredible speaker Carissa
Sanborn mat-su who's a principal
investigator at Los Alamos National Lab
little bit of background on Carissa she
became interested in chaos theory while
studying physics at Columbia University
in New York
she then went on to study nonlinear
dynamics in particular in astrophysics
in Boulder in Colorado and then she took
a rather circuitous route via New Mexico
with an interest into the origin of life
and then currently epigenetics she works
on the bleeding edge of genomics so
investigating all of those mechanisms
above and beyond
the rather simple determinism of DNA
helping us to understand inheritance
individual variability and our subtle
responses to the environment life it
turns out is far more complex than we
ever thought and that makes us at the
Santa Fe Institute very happy so please
join me in welcoming Carissa
I love you
we're in a relationship when do you say
I love you for the first time when do
you define the relationship and when do
you make the relationship Facebook
official well we all know the symptoms
of love you know the butterflies in your
stomach your hands getting clammy so
nervous you're terrified but you can't
wait for more there's a lot going on
when you fall in love you thought it was
just a bunch of heartache and money your
brain goes through all kinds of changes
your brain is flooded with oxytocin a
love chemical falling in love is
physiological on the other hand since
the time you could walk you've heard
stories about love from everyone so is
the ability to fall in love genetically
programmed or were you conditioned to
fall in love well we don't know
well what exactly do we mean by nature
versus nurture
but what's by nature what we mean are
things that are instinctual or hardwired
into your DNA so things like
physiological traits that are heavily
influenced by genetics
some examples include migrating geese so
the the idea when the geese are
genetically programmed to know exactly
when and where to go at what time of the
year another thing that could be
hardwired is your your personality and
then finally many things that are
hardwired are studied in twin studies
now what do we mean by nurture well
these are more learned behaviors so
things like for example a toddler
throwing a temper tantrum and always
getting what they want that's kind of a
learned behavior also maybe a dog
learning to balance three oranges on its
head another learned behavior
you know and then also what we do in the
lab doing molecular biology that's a
learned behavior as well now there's a
third class of phenomena that's that are
not really nature and not nurture but
somewhere in between in this more
nebulous area and these include things
like anxiety and stress or stress
disorders there it's not so clear if
this was hardwired into your DNA or was
it a result of growing up in a very
stressful environment maybe another
thing is laughter believe it or not we
don't really understand right now if if
laughter is something learned or is it
genetically programmed their studies and
prime means showing that the ability to
laugh is sort of taught to the to the
younglings but on the other hand they're
also arguments that it could be genetic
as well and then intelligence is another
controversial subject and then also the
ability to fall in love another so this
brings us to what we call epigenetics
and so epigenetics is sort of a layer
above the DNA and phenom illogically egg
results in these kinds of traits that
are sort of not nature and not nurture
but somewhere in between it's sort of a
layer of circuitry over the DNA that
determines when and where genes are
turned on and off and an interesting
metaphor for epigenetics is your
smartphone so if you think of your
smartphone as like the DNA or the
hardware of your smartphone then the
software or the app on your smartphone
is like an epigenetic program and then
finally the output of that app would be
like the cell fate so for example if
your app is something like Google Maps
and you needed to suppose like when
you're coming to the lens ik tonight
you're trying to figure out exactly
where to park and you want to look up on
Google Maps where to park you use your
your Google map app and then the result
of using the app as it gives you the
directions to get here and similarly
these cells have epigenetic programs
that are sort of a layer of software on
top of the DNA that can convert a cell
into
a blood cell or a brain cell or such as
the embryo is developing and the egg is
developing in the bloom oops sorry
okay I just back up it's a little
squirrely the control here okay so just
to give you a basic overview of what DNA
is DNA is basically a long polymer or a
long string like molecule and it's
composed of millions of these chemical
bases you may have heard them as AG C NT
or Addison guanine cytosine and thymine
and these millions of bases are
organized in units called genes and so
one gene is basically one segment of DNA
that codes for a protein and those
proteins are the things that do the
actual work in your cells and this is
sort of the basic makeup of DNA and then
here is a 3d image of a DNA molecule and
this is magnified you know millions of
times and so here we're looking at the
length scale of one nanometer and these
are the chemical bases that I was
talking to you about that make up the
DNA and nowadays people are able to go
to particle accelerators and use very
powerful x-ray beams and blast DNA to
get diffraction patterns an image DNA
you know in atomic resolution and it's
it takes the shape of this famous double
helix discovered by Watson and Crick you
know in the in the mid 1900s
now there's sort of a packing problem
that goes along with with DNA so there's
enough DNA inside your body to wrap
around the entire earth several million
times so it's a lot of DNA and so
somehow all that DNA has to get packed
inside your body in such an organized
fashion that it can basically control
everything that happens in your body and
the question is how does nature solve
that problem well the answer is there
are millions of chemical spools that
wind up the DNA so in each cell there
are thousands and thousands of these
spools that sort of store the DNA and
then what epigenetics is it's this
circuitry that sort of unwinds and winds
up the spool is it's just the right
times in just the right moments and so
here are some other visualizations of
the DNA wrapped around these spools that
the jargon name for the spool is called
a histone and so here we're looking at a
micrograph with the length scale of 0.1
microns and you can see in three
dimensions these red histone spools and
the DNA is in gray and it's where it's
wound around those spools so these this
is a DNA wrapped around the histones and
the amazing thing is that this intricate
network of spools is highly highly
programmable and it's what takes a
fertilized egg all the way up to an
embryo to an adult human all those
decisions that are made to differentiate
cells into different kinds of cell types
are made through controlling the this
network of spools or systems and so this
is essentially what epigenetics is it's
this layer above the DNA that allows the
DNA to be programmed so the DNA is
organized into genes and then the genes
are wrapped around these spools and when
the spool is unwind then the DNA that
then the genes can be turned on and off
at the right moments and this this
overall process is called epigenetics
there's something above genetics and so
again if we go back to this analogy with
the smartphone
just to hammer this home you know the
smartphone is the hardware or the like
the DNA is the hardware and then the app
on the phone this is the epigenetic
program the switching on and off of all
the different genes at the right moments
especially during development of an egg
but it also happens throughout your life
and then again the output during
development is like the cell fate it's
that's shown here and so this is an yet
another visualization of this process so
here we have the DNA wound around these
histone spools here and then in addition
one other complication that happens is
that these histone spools these are
essentially bundles of proteins they
contain these little tails hanging off
this wall and the tails are at those are
the actual switches that allow the
spools to be programmed and what happens
as different factors are flying around
the cell and they interact with those
tails and they can charge the tail and
they can cause these large-scale changes
of of thousands of spools - very kind of
compact confirmations are very loose
spread out confirmations and this is one
of these programmers that charges one of
the tails and so so again the idea is
that each spool has a chemical switch on
it and when it's switched on the spools
open up and then the cell can then
access the gene and be in between those
spools and that's the on-state here's
another example of the on-state with the
orange region is accessible to the to
the cell and then it allows the gene to
be turned on now in the opposite case
when we're in the off state here the
histones or the spool is condensed to a
very compact conformation and in that
case the genes are no longer exposed to
the cell so that it would be the off
state here's that orange region that was
necessary for the gene to be turned on
is now hidden by all these spools that
are tightly bound
okay so I wanted to try to demonstrate
this
with this physical mock-up I have here
and so here so the idea is here this is
I have to give credit to my cat willow
because mom
willow help me put the stickers on this
hose so it took about three hours and he
was very good at keeping me company and
so the idea here is that but you can
imagine the hose it's like a strand of
DNA and so here I have four different
colors like green for guanine read for
thymine yellow for you for cytosine and
green and another and orange for adenine
for example and if if we tried to like
scale this model up you know if the
thickness of this hose were the same as
the thickness of a molecule DNA there'd
be about 10,000 miles of hose packed in
this auditorium so if you can imagine
you know going to Home Depot and doing
an order well you probably have to like
do a huge order for 10 bells and hoses
you know and then somehow have them
flying around in this theater that's
what it would look like inside the cell
and then these garden hose spools are
like the histones the molecular spools
and they wind up the hose and so the
idea is in some situations the gene is
turned on and the hoses are spread out
and and you have this orange region
would be like the gene activation region
and this would be exposed to the cells
so if I'm a factor you know I could come
flying around and then I could you know
activate that gene and so forth and then
this year is like the switch in this
case it's a lysine and so to be more
accurate if I'm the factor I wouldn't
touch that region I would just charge
this part the lysine and then that would
trigger the winding of these spools to
so if I want to shut off the gene I
could charge that lysine and then I
could sort of wine these together
so we'll just kind of do the best we can
again okay yeah yeah that's what this
would be kind of a defect in the winding
over their head
this guy whining buzzer so that could be
a genetic disease
okay so then here so anyway you get the
idea so now this would be the off state
and so it's so again if you can imagine
sort of thousands of those plastic
spools you know hovering around in this
theater and sort of unwinding and
winding it's just the right times in
just the right moments
that's the epigenetic programming that's
happening in all yourselves right now at
this moment okay
end of demo and up in Los Alamos we do a
lot of different things we do some
computer modeling and we do a lot in the
wet lab as well and so here's one of our
computer models that were running on the
supercomputers up in Los Alamos and this
is a three-dimensional view of these
spools and this is magnified around a
hundred million times and so we're
running this on our new supercomputer
called Trinity which is coming out it's
on half of its online now and the rest
is supposed to come online this summer
it currently ranks at number six in the
world and we're hoping to get close to
number one when it's fully online and so
you can see these two spools are sort of
closer together and then what happens is
when it's flooded with things like
oxytocin it triggers the spools - on
mine just like the garden houses and
then the purple region would be the
activation region that turns the stress
response on so we can watch again we
have two histone spools and the DNA is
wound around the histone spools and then
when these sort of ghosts like serotonin
molecules are flying all around it
triggers different factors to come and
charge the histones and then this
unwinding of
sports this is not in real times now
okay so one thing that's kind of spurred
this whole explosion of epigenetics
research in the last five years or so
has been new DNA sequencing technology
so epigenetic effects have been known
for a while but in the last five years
has sort of been a flurry of activity in
the research community where everyone's
trying to really hone in on how exactly
do these epigenetic effects work at the
atomistic level and in addition people
are trying to figure out where and when
do the epigenetic effects happened what
kinds of tissues what stages during
development what how many weeks after
conception in the womb how about in
early childhood and so forth and now
with the new DNA sequencing technology
were able to get dnh whole genome
sequences for different tissue types for
all kinds of different patients and so
forth and sort of this Holy Grail has
now been reached where I think a while
ago people were sort of setting this
grand challenge to do a whole genome
sequence for $1,000 and and that was
reached about about a year ago I guess
and so now it's it's very commonplace to
do to do full genomes and in addition
you can use this technology to get the
to effectively get the epigenetic
programs on top of the DNA and sort of
the killer app for this technology is
stem cell programming and so the idea
here is that you you begin with sort of
a blank slate on your epigenetic program
you know the egg is fertilized and then
that egg divides into two and those two
divided into two and so on and so forth
until you get a ball of cells and then
the inside the womb and then that ball
of cells changes as well in different
parts of the ball turn into arms and
heads and eyes and everything
and it's often epigenetic switching that
makes these decisions for the cell-fate
to take one cell into a blood cell and
one cell into an eye cell and so forth
and so you can imagine it's very
important to understand how that works
so when things go wrong you know you if
if the epigenetics is not working right
you know you may have an arm growing out
of your eye or something like that and
that's something we don't want and a
long time ago a famous person called
Waddington drew this picture of
something called the epigenetic
landscape and this is just another
visualization of how we think the
switching is is happening and the ideas
that you begin with your fertilized egg
and then if you track single cells so
that the egg will divide into two and
those two into four and so forth and if
you follow one of those cells throughout
its whole lifetime until the baby is
born for example you know did that cell
turn into a skin cell or blood cell or
what and the idea is that at every point
during development decisions have to be
made to go to the left or to the right
and then as more and more of those
decisions are made it specializes in to
the final adult cell and so you could
have a blood cell or a brain cell and
it's kind of analogous to ASCII tale and
so suppose you're you're going skiing up
at Santa Fe ski area or if you happen to
be at heavenly in California you have an
enormous number of decisions to make you
know as you're skiing down there's
always a fork in the road or a fork in
the ski trails where you have to go left
or you have to go right and a lot of
these decisions need to be made and so
you may start up at the top here and and
there's always these Forks in the road
so you may want to go to a double black
diamond if you're feeling you know more
ambitious or you could go
take it easy on no grit and do it do it
easier to blue slope and then suppose
you may want to go for some wide-open
powder fields or maybe hit the snowboard
pipe and then do some gambling you
in that case you'd want to go to the
Nevada side and in addition there this
analogy is also nice because it can show
you how you can start at the bottom go
up to the top and then make different
decisions so suppose you're in the
parking lot here and you want to end up
in Nevada or somewhere else
you may take a gondola up all the way up
to the top and then go down to the
finish line here and so the analogy here
is that as the fertilized egg is
developing you know different decisions
have to be made to get down to those
landscape and to convert the cells into
the different kinds of cells they need
to be converted into like a brain cell
or a blood cell so to get to one month a
lot of different decisions have to be
made and then two months and fourteen
months and so forth to get blood and
brain cells and immune cells and heart
cells and so on and so forth and then in
addition there's also the concept of
reprogramming so a lot of epigenetics
happens to take the egg all the way up
to a baby and then as far as stem cells
go the idea is to to start with an adult
skin cell for example and can we wipe
the slate clean erase all the epigenetic
marks and switches and then start with a
blank slate and then program it into
like a kidney cell or a heart cell or
something like that and so the idea
there is you want to add some special
protein mix to that cell to erase all
the marks and get it all the way up to
this blank slate and then change it into
some other kind of cell and that's sort
of the concept behind stem cell
programming and so why is there so much
excitement about epigenetics so again
the basic concept is that you have your
DNA and genes and then epigenetics is
this layer programming that can kind of
turn things on and off well it turns out
that a lot of these switches happen
during pregnancy
they happen and also they happen
throughout your your whole life so in
pregnancy and then as you're growing up
different kinds of epigenetic changes
happen and also different chemicals in
the environment can actually seriously
alter the epigenetic switching and cause
permanent changes to your genes and then
in addition many of these changes can be
permanent so they can last for your
whole life and then they can also be
passed down to up to four generations so
not only to the kids and the grandkids
but in some cases to the
great-grandchildren and then finally one
of the most intriguing things with
epigenetics is that social interactions
can also induce epigenetic changes so
things like stress during early
childhood can actually alter the
epigenetic program and those effects can
persist throughout your entire life and
I'll talk I'll go into detail on one of
those examples soon and then finally the
sort of the latest research that's
coming out is there's a lot of positive
effects that can come about with
different epigenetic processes as well
so the the main example I want to talk
about today is about and it's in rodents
and how mother rats nurture their young
and the effect that has on epigenetic
programming and on stress response so if
we go back to our question of nature
versus nurture remember that by nature
we meant things that are genetically
programmed or hardwired and by nurture
we mean things that are learned by
experience so as far as the stress
response goes you know the genetically
hardwired version might be that some
people are just born they can't be
rattled no matter what they're just
genetically unstress it'll you know
whereas other other people might be
what's easily startled by by anything
that goes bump in the night and then as
far as that the nurture argument goes
there the idea might be if you grow up
in a really stressful atmosphere maybe
that affects your
ability to deal with stress later in
life or likewise maybe if you have a
stressful job that could also affect
your stress response as well and to
discuss this example of the rats the
mommy rats nurturing their young and so
forth it's useful to think a little bit
about of the mechanism on how stress and
stress response works in your body and
one analogy is that of just in baseball
a pitcher and a catcher so if you so you
know in baseball you have a pitcher that
throws the ball and then catcher and
catches the ball so there's the ball
going and the kitchen visitor so that
did not require the super computers that
was Alamos
okay so that the the analogy here is the
ball is sort of like the stress hormone
or cortisol and so when when a stressful
event happens you get a lot of cortisol
that's excreted and then if everything's
working hunky-dory
you have this cortisol receptor that
catches the the cortisol hormone and so
if everything's working right you know
you may you know something stressful
might happen like someone took your
parking space or something like that and
all this cortisol gets released and
starts flooding your brain but then you
have the cortisol receptors so the
cortisol receptors realize that's
happening they catch all the cortisol
and you had that stressful event but but
it's not going to kill you because
someone took your parking space okay so
next we can go into this in a little bit
more detail and so again if you have the
stressful event happen you have the
cortisol excreted and you get cortisol
receptor production and then the
receptors catch those cortisol molecules
and you have the happy response now to
talk about things going out of whack a
little I want to say a little bit about
thermostats and so because we're going
to talk about stress thermostats so in
your normal thermostat at home you know
that the thermostat sort of controls the
temperature in your house and so here if
you if you set your thermostat to 68
degrees I set it to 78 degrees actually
in my house but on it and it gets cold
outside then what happens is or your cat
is covered in snow else I think so then
what happens as your heater is supposed
to kick in you know and the heater turns
on but then when you get to in my case
78 degrees then everything's fine but
sorry the clicker is going a little too
fast but what what can happen is the the
thermostat can get go out of whack
sometimes as many of you may have
experienced where it just keeps getting
and hotter and hotter and then it's it's
not working you know so then Homer has
to sit in his underwear and so forth
okay okay so the analogy here is that if
there's a stressful event that happens
the stress response is very important to
get right and there's also a stress
thermostat in your bodies that helps you
deal with stress and so the idea is that
when a stressful event happens cortisol
is is flooding your your brain basically
but there may not be any cortisol
receptors there so the cortisol
production may not be doing exactly what
it's supposed to be doing and in that
case you can end up with very high
cortisol levels and then you can end up
with a very poor stress response and so
so that's basically a primer on on
stress response in the biochemistry of
it so now I want to talk to you about
this landmark study in epigenetics done
by a great group in Montreal and here
they looked at mother rats licking and
grooming their pups and the effect it
has on DNA and the effect it has on
stress response not only during
childhood but all the way up through
adulthood and into future generations
and so here they looked at two
populations of rats so in population
number one the mothers were very good at
licking and grooming their young so
they're kind of spoiling their young you
know driving them to soccer practice
giving them massages all the time you
know these are really nurturing mothers
now on the other hand there is a second
population where the mothers were not so
good at licking and grooming their young
and sort of neglected them a little bit
and what they did is they monitored the
stress levels and they also monitored
the response to stress in terms of
behavior so they subjected the the pups
to different tests like dropping them in
water or facing them with a predator and
so forth and seeing do they really freak
out or they or do they have a normal
stress response
and then finally they were able to look
at the epigenetic switches on on the DNA
at the stress response gene
and so in population number one in this
case what would happen is the babies
would get serotonin released which is
sort of a feel-good chemical when they
when they were nurtured and so forth in
that case they would look at the
epigenetics in here the stress response
receptors were on and then that would
result in a normal level of stress
receptors so then when a stressful event
did happen they could respond very
nicely to that stressful response and
then finally in population number two in
this case where the mothers did not
nurture their pups here when you had a
stressful event resulting in cortisol
production in that case the receptors
were were turned off instead of being
turned on and so you didn't get the
receptor production and then you would
have the angry or the poorer stress
response and so the interesting thing is
that when they looked at the DNA they
did see these the marks coinciding with
receptor off and in one case and
receptor on in the other and then in
addition they also saw higher rates of
diabetes and cancer in these animals and
finally not only did the poor stress
response persist through adulthood but
in successive generations of the of the
rats and so they would see these marks
persists for many generations so now we
can talk a little bit about other
studies so there have been some
interesting studies in in mice where
they've looked at effects on not only
the children and grandchildren but
great-grandchildren and this is by a
group from Skinner and coworkers
and in these cases they looked at
different effects such as jet fuel and
pesticides beasts phenol a whoops bees
and bees phenol a and so in this case
they saw that the pups had fewer eggs
and also
a large number of variances and these
persisted all the way through to the
great-grandchildren so this it's
interesting that these epigenetic
effects once once these switches are
switched it persists for many
generations and then in humans there
been some interesting studies done so
one has shown that child abuse alters
the epigenetic profile in the
post-mortem brain another one showed
that stress on the mother caused by
violence of a partner caused epigenetics
on the same cortisol receptor in the
blood of the of adolescents and they've
also looked they've also seen marks in
populations with higher rates of suicide
and also there's a lot of exciting
research going on in autism now where
they see this oxytocin receptor gene
turned off every genetically and so so
right now there's sort of no there's not
a whole lot of smoking guns I would say
in human studies but what they're doing
is they're just finding a lot of
correlations with epigenetic marks on
the DNA and then these different kinds
of things happening now as far as
positive effects go some of the latest
research that's being done I'm looking
at more positive things so there's a
group in Sweden looking at exercise and
I was at a conference a few years ago
and the one person who showed a poster
where they saw from a single workout
they could see epigenetic marks at these
fat storage cell sites and then in more
long-term they looked at a population
with six months of of exercise and they
could see that these fat gene fat
epigenetic circuits were reprogrammed
and then some very exciting studies are
showing recovery of lost memory in mice
and and in these cases they're they're
starting to come up with epigenetic
drugs that kind of kind of freeze these
epigenetic programmers and so kind of
the state of the art now and as far as
epigenetic drugs go is that they're more
sort of almost analogous to
broad-spectrum antibiotics where they're
sort of hitting epigenetic factors in
all the cells in your body and then
hoping that it
does some good and in a lot of case it
is and sort of the future is about
making things more specific to specific
tissues and so forth okay so now I
wanted to say a few words about cancer
this is one of the active areas of
research in epigenetics and drug design
for epigenetic effects and so if we can
go back to our smartphone metaphor now
remember before we said that the DNA is
kind of like the hardware and then the
epigenetic program is kind of like the
app and then the cell fate was kind of
like the output of that app well if we
take the analogy a little bit further we
can talk about these epigenetic factors
are sort of the programmers that program
the app and that the epigenetic marks or
switching states are kind of like the
settings in your in your smartphone and
so right now these the cancer drugs that
are out there now sort of freeze all the
settings and in all the cells and they
hope it does some good you know it's
better than something like chemotherapy
that's sort of trying to kill all the
cells and in this case you're not
killing the cell you're just freezing
the epigenetic programmers and and
freezing those settings so it's kind of
a more subtle effect than your normal
chemotherapy and so when we think about
cancer the idea is that the sort of a
big-picture view the idea is that you
have tumor suppressor genes and then you
have oncogenes and so the tumor
suppressor genes help suppress the tumor
growth and then the oncogenes promote
the tumor growth and then in a healthy
individual you always have this balance
so we all have tumor suppressor genes
and we all have oncogenes but there's
always got to be a balance between the
two and then when things go out of
balance that's when you can get cancer
and so we can go back to our ski trail
metaphor and like I was saying before
that when you start a cell from sort of
an embryo state it has to divide and
differentiate and then it can turn into
a blood cell or a brain cell or an
immune cell or a heart cell well in
addition it could also turn into a tumor
cell as well and so it's important to
understand you know how this process
worked and how epigenetics control
the change of these cells and so ideally
what the the goal here is to start with
a cancer cell and then reprogram it so
wipe out all its epigenetic marks and
take it to the top of the hill and then
let it be programmed into a cell that
can actually be beneficial to your body
rather than taking it away from you and
so as far as the epigenetics goes in in
just normal cells as I was saying before
you can imagine it as these you know
thousands of these plastic spools
hovering in in the auditorium and
turning things on and off and so forth
well it's going to turn the tumor
suppressor genes on and you're going to
have your uncle genes turned off and
then in addition there's sort of a third
class of genes that are important for
cancer and these I just call sort of DNA
chaos genes where they could cause kind
of swapping of different parts of genes
from from one spot to another and in
those case you also want those turned
off in a normal cell but in in cancer
cells what happens is that the tumor
suppressors the things that are supposed
to suppress the tumors are actually off
resulting in in tumor growth and then
the oncogenes are turned on also
resulting in tumor growth and then there
are also other kinds of situations where
these so called DNA chaos genes are also
turned on causing you know widespread
swapping of genetic elements and so
forth and some other kinds of
programming epigenetic programming
errors that happen is sometimes you can
have just too many epigenetic
programmers out there and this happens
in breast cancer in leukemia and
prostate cancer and in liver cancer in
addition you can have the wrong
programming team present or the wrong
kinds of factors present so that would
be for example if you had an Android
phone but you had like your team of Mac
programmers trying to debug it and
they're not doing too well and then
finally you can have a situation where
your spools are sort of at the wrong
place on on the genome and so the spools
are not not where they should be those
are other kinds of epigenetic errors
that can affect cancer and then as far
as epigenetic cancer drugs go as I
mentioned the traditional cancer drug is
to sort of kill the entire cell for both
cancers and non cancerous cells and
that's why in chemotherapy they'll be
really nasty side-effects that you get
and it practically kills you when you
have to go through chemotherapy and the
idea in epigenetics is to block all the
programmers in both cancers and non
cancerous cells but at least it halts
for example the DNA chaos genes from
being turned on and so forth and then
the ultimate goal is to sort of
reprogram these cells rather than than
kill the cells and right now there are a
few epigenetic drugs on the market these
are more broad spectrum and I just read
an article they're expecting the
epigenetic drug market to grow to like
30 billion and by the year 2020 I think
so it's a really exploding feel as far
as drug drug development goes okay so
that was sort of a little blurb on key
on cancer and epigenetics and lastly I
want to talk a little bit about what
we're doing up in Los Alamos and so here
what we're trying to focus on is is a
huge outstanding question in epigenetics
so I I told you about the spools these
plastic garden hose bowl is floating
around in the theatre and the hose
winding and unwinding and those spools
they have to sort of wind and unwind at
just the right spot in just the right
moment now the big question is how do
they know when to unwind and when to
wind how do they know how to do it right
at the right time and also right at the
right place this no one really has any
good idea and it turns out that somehow
the factors come and turn them on in the
right spots at the right moments and
there's some kind of recruiting
mechanism that must happen that can
sense what's happening so some kind of
communication has to happen where
somehow the cell the information of the
environment of the cell is speaking to
these spools telling them what's going
on in the cell and and the question is
how does that communication occur and
that's what we're working on in Los
Alamos and we think the answer is RNA
and RNA is sort of this cousin of AB DNA
and so our group is focused on
understanding how the RNA can talk to
the spools and trigger these different
effects and so here's just sort of a
crude cartoon of what we think is
happening and again we have these spools
that the DNA is wound around and then we
have the factors that do the switching
and somehow the spools have to talk to
the factors and then what we think is
happening is that these RNA molecules
are being synthesized from the DNA and
then they're folding into specific
shapes and then recruiting these
epigenetic factors to the DNA and then
they can bind and make their switching
marks on the DNA or on the histone
spools and just to give you a one slide
summary of what RNAi is and why it's
important this is that yeah there are
like thousands of people working on this
for like 50 years but so RNAi it's kind
of like DNA's molecular cousin and and
it's kind of like the it's kind of like
a disgruntled teenager I'm not sure how
to say it's like it's never appreciated
you know and so so our DNA everyone
knows what DNA is it has the blueprint
of your genome and it stores all the
information for your body you know on
that molecule and then what happens is
the DNA is converted into proteins and
the proteins do all the work they make
up all the structures and they do all
the chemistry and so forth so I can be
talking to you right now and for a long
time people thought RNA was just a sort
of go-between it would just like read
what's on the DNA and then turn it into
proteins and that's what RNA did but in
the last 10 years or so it's been found
that RNA actually can stand on its own
and really do its own thing and so it's
been found that RNA can do lots of great
things in the cells they can do
chemistry
it can make structures and can do all
kinds of
of different things and one thing that
it's it does a lot of epigenetic
switching and epigenetic programming and
people think it may be this sort of
missing link to recruit those
programming factors to the DNA and so
when you have your strand of RNA it has
a sequence just like DNA has a sequence
and then one thing about RNA though is
it can fold up into more complicated
shapes so DNA pretty much just folds up
into this double helix the famous double
helix and that can bend around a little
bit but it's basically a double helix
but RNA can do lots of more fold so it
can make these cloverleaf shapes and it
can make all kinds of different shapes
that have Ulysses in them but they're
kind of warped and twisted and put
together in different ways and so forth
and then in 3d this is what a little
piece of RNA looks like that does
something and so what we're doing in Los
Alamos is trying to map out the
structures of some of these epigenetic
RNAs and so it's been found that a whole
new class of RNAs exists that's
responsible for epigenetic effects and
this has got long non-coding RNAs and
sort of the coding RNAs are the ones
that these go between sis going from the
DNA and making protein DNA making
protein DNA making protein but these
non-coding RNAs are what people used to
think were just junk or at least I call
it junk DNA and so forth but it actually
the the the junk actually does a lot of
important stuff and many people believe
that these RNAs are really critical for
almost every different kind of
epigenetic effect and so what we're
doing is we're trying to map out what
these are knees look like and sort of an
outstanding question in this new field
of long rnas is that do these RNAs have
any structure at all sort of are they
just sort of like floppy like wound up
and tangled in a bowl of spaghetti or
are they really organized and highly
structured and can they sense what's
happening in the cell and then talk to
these spools and so what we're finding
is that they do seem to have structure
we've looked at about four of these RNAs
now this is the first one we looked at
called the steroid receptor
an activator and this is an RNA that's
responsible for up regulating the
estrogen response in human and it also
interacts with many other hormones and
so we we map the structure of this and
this was done by Armenia novikova and
Scott Henley in the lab also with some
help from Ashutosh Dara pincer doll
Hermes Alton and they were able to find
that this particular RNA had all kinds
of structures you know 20-some HeLa C's
making lots of intricate interactions
and so forth and so this isn't you know
this is just sort of the first step in
figuring out what these rnase do but
it's a very interesting result and so
sort of the cutting edge of epigenetics
one of the key questions is sort of how
does the DNA know what's going on in the
cell and how do these spools know when
to wind and unwind and we think the
answer may lie in in RNA and these RNAs
have been linked to a lot of different
things like Alzheimer's and autism and
different different kinds of important
phenomena and so one kind of interesting
idea or in these Santa Fe lectures were
supposed to present one controversial
idea and so this concert this idea is
that this is what I believe and so
they're sort of like it's hard to
explain but they're kind of RNA people
and then there are there are people who
are not RNA people and so and so the RNA
people tend to be diehard Pro RNA like
no matter what and so I think many
people in the RNA community believe that
the the so maybe teeming with these long
RNA is just everywhere you look there
these long RNA is doing all kinds of
stuff and that they may be highly highly
structured and the controversy now is
are they just flopping around like
spaghetti are they really very
intricately structured and we believe
that maybe there's many of them that are
intricately structured and there are a
lot of studies showing that there's many
of these non-coding RNAs as there are
proteins let's that's interesting and I
think each year there's more and more
evidence coming out that yes these RNAs
are are really important and really
in epigenetics and so as far as the
future of epigenetics goes we're sort of
just at the baby stages now as in terms
of actual mechanism and figuring out
what's going on a de mystically in what
causes what and so forth but the good
thing is that there's just tons of data
coming out each year and with the cheap
new sequencing technology there's just
going to be more and more data
especially this sort of personalized
data for different patients and
different cell types lots of human
studies and then and the drug companies
are really pouring money into this
problem as well and they're they're very
interested in this as well and so with
all this progress it kind of brings us
back to our beginning question we're
open is how do we know we're in love how
do you know you're in love and we don't
really know the answer to that now but
maybe in the future when your kids ask
you how do you know you're in love you
might be able to answer well it's simple
you know when histone 3 is chemically
modified and so that's how you know
you're in